-Our next guest is best known
for her role
as Hilda Spellman
on the ABC hit series
"Sabrina The Teenage Witch,"
as well as her --
[ Cheers and applause ]
As well as her numerous
comedy specials.
She will be performing at the
Epic Events Center in Green Bay,
November 18th.
Please welcome the very funny
Caroline Rhea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi!
Thank you.
I'm so happy to be in New York.
I live in Los Angeles now,
and everyone is very concerned
with their appearance there.
[ Light laughter ]
Like, people always say to me,
"Caroline, your face is so full.
What kind of filler do you use?
Is it Restylane or Juvederm?"
I'm like, "Fudge."
[ Laughter ]
"I put a little
rocky road right here."
[ Laughter ]
"And then this is vanilla.
Yeah."
And they're fussy eaters.
I have one friend,
she is so gluten-intolerant,
she can't even listen
to Hall & Oates.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I was ghosted
by a man in his 70s. Yeah.
I'm hoping he was just so old
he died and became a ghost.
[ Laughter ]
So now I'm on this amazing
dating app, Taskrabbit.
I love it.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it gets the job done.
I live in a 100-year-old house,
and, seriously,
I feel like my house
is just an old man
who married me for my money.
[ Laughter ]
No, it really is.
It's like an old man.
Like, the foundation,
it's not hard anymore.
[ Laughter ]
There's very little wood.
It takes forever for any water
to come out of the pipes, and --
[ Laughter ]
There's a lot of
spontaneous gas leaks
that it blames on the dog, so...
[ Laughter ]
I have one friend
who's obsessed with astrology.
I mean, like, a crazy person.
Admittedly, I did have to have
an emergency C-section
because I was very high risk
for having a Scorpio.
[ Laughter ]
And, um...
Yeah, there was no way
I wanted my daughter born
that good at sex
and unable to forgive, so...
[ Laughter ]
Wasn't gonna happen.
Yeah.
I hate when people pretend they
don't know what sign they are.
Like, I asked this man
in Georgia.
I go "What sign are you?"
And he goes, "I have no idea."
I go, "Well, how old are you?"
He's like, "56."
I go, "In 56 years,
no one has ever mentioned
what sign you are?"
And he said,
"Um, I think I'm a 'lib-ra.'"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, a lib-ra.
Did you read about that
in a 'hor-os-copy' book?"
[ Laughter ]
"I thought perhaps you were
a 'ge-meanie' or a 'pish-ez.'"
[ Laughter ]
"Maybe a 'vir-jo' or a 'canker,'
but you look like
a 'saggy-tit-a-raurus.'
You really do."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
My ex-boyfriend was a cancer --
in many ways.
He, um --
[ Laughter ]
He was actually a lib-ra.
So, I had my daughter in my 40s,
and of course I breast-fed.
And no one was more shocked
than my boobs, okay?
[ Laughter ]
They'd been understudies
their entire life,
and they were like, "What?
We're going on?"
[ Laughter ]
"I don't even know
if I remember the part."
[ Laughter ]
Having a teenager
and being a comedian,
it often feels like the heckler
just followed me home
from the club.
[ Laughter ]
She's so mean.
She's like, "That's not funny."
[ Light laughter ]
"What happened to your hair?
You smell like ranch."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "I do?"
It's so pathetic 'cause
all I want to do is please her.
And I was watching
"House of the Dragon."
I was very disappointed.
I thought it was just about
raising a teenager.
And --
[ Laughter ]
'Cause my daughter,
she's like an evil queen,
and I'm like this pathetic
troll servant
who endlessly tries
to please her.
Like -- and I make a big deal
of everything.
Even if I bring her, like,
a coffee, I'm like this.
[ Laughter ]
"My lady!"
"I bring you a frozen potion.
Made of almond milk
and the spice of a pumpkin."
[ Laughter ]
"1/3 decaf, no foam.
Grande in a vente cup,
as you have demanded."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's like this,
"Did you say almond milk?
Are you trying to ruin
the environment?"
[ Laughter ]
"I asked for oat milk.
Take it away."
"A thousand pardons, my lady."
[ Laughter ]
And then she's like, "Mummy,
will you take me to the mall?"
"I shall prepare the carriage
and the bag of gold."
[ Laughter ]
So, of course,
to do everything
for my daughter,
I got her a dog.
And so, one day, the dog
was sitting on my lap,
and she viciously bit me
on the nipple.
[ Audience groans ]
Do you have any idea
how painful it is to realize
that your nipple
is accessible from your lap?
[ Laughter ]
Those were real tears.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much!
I'm Caroline Rhea.
♪♪
-I mean, stop it!
Come on, now.
Come on!
Come over here.
Caroline Rhea!
We'll be right back
with more from Caroline!
Come on, come on!